quand elle dégustera sa galette cette
cliente aura une surprise dans sa
frangipane pas de santons en porcelaine
mais des fèves en verre pour le patron
loïc d'où ces deux mots d'ordre
originalité et surtout proximité dans ma
vision des choses moi je travaille avec
beaucoup de local et vu ce qui se passe
en ce moment dans la conjoncture
actuelle
c'était très très bien le faire
travailler le petit à petit artisan
verrier à côté d'eux à côté de
l'entreprise
la créatrice c'est elle corinne à l'art
verrier fondeur depuis plus de 30 ans
dans son petit atelier tout est fait à
la main
chaque modèle est unique le principe
c'est donc c'est de prendre des morceaux
de verre que je découpe à froid que
j'assemble pour donner la forme et la
couleur que je désire et ensuite je mets
à cuire dans un four à peu près 850
degrés pendant une douzaine d'heures et
j'obtiens une fève terminée ils peuvent
être transformés en bijoux ou en
accessoires pour la pour l'art de la
table elle travaille sur ces fèves
depuis le mois de novembre
car un boulanger de fontainebleau lui en
a aussi commandé pour l'instant elle a
fabriqué près de 500 pièces ce projet
c'est une première
ce qui a été difficile ça a été donc de
réaliser 500 fèves pièces uniques
donc il a fallu vraiment réfléchir à
chaque fois avant un dessin il ya
quelque chose de différent pour chaque
faible pour qu'elle soit restée unique
et 500 ça fait quand même beaucoup de
réflexion les pièces uniques qui peuvent
avoir une seconde vie
pourtant au premier abord elles ont du
mal à trouver leur public
le client l'habitude d'avoir des fèves
un peu fantaisie avec astérix
l faut faire faut avoir beaucoup de
communication faire ses basses un
message par bon avec le fait que c'est
du local ça marche très très bien
il faut dire que ces trois fois plus
cher comptez moins d'un euro pour des
pièces classiques contre 2 euros 50 pour
ses fèves en verre